Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro!
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Now, today's Maestro Hook is a good conversation piece that you can use with a foreigner.
Now, today's Hook is about using animals as a reference when you're speaking in English...
...especially in terms of idioms.
Now, there're a lot of idioms that use animals, but there are some that are very old we never use.
For example, a lot of Japanese people know "It's raining cats and dogs",...
...but my grandmother doesn't even use that.
It's so old.
So, please don't use it.
On the other hand, a joke like, "Why did the chicken cross the road?", is always good.
So, there're a lot of animal phrases that we use...
...and some are good, some are not. So, let's check out some that you can really actually use.
It's a wild-goose chase.
Wild-goose chase.
It's a crocodile.
It's a crocodile tear.
Crocodile tear.
Oh! It's a crocodile tear.
Okay. So, two lines and today's Maestro Lines.
Oh! It's a wild-goose chase; I went all over the town, but I couldn't find what I wanted to find.
Ah! It was a wild-goose chase.
She was crying, but I bet it's a crocodile tear.
I bet it's a crocodile tear.
Okay. So, that's it for today.
A lot of animal English and use the ones that are pretty fresh, okay?
And I'll see you later, and hope to catch you again!
Now, see you later on Native Maestro.
Bye-bye!